foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled
panel presentation authenticated and
reproducible cell line omics data this
webinar is part of the sixth annual
event in the drug Discovery and
development virtual event series and I'm
Susie Valdez of lab roots and I will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and sponsored by kyogen for
more information about kyogen go to
kyogen.com now let's get started before
we begin I want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you first to participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during this
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the left of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
Send if you have any child people seeing
or hearing this presentation just simply
click on that help desk button located
at the top of your screen within the
navigation bar or from the lobby and
finally you will notice that the sponsor
has provided a polling question located
to the right and of the ask a question
box and that polling question will be
available during both the live session
and the on demand period
I now want to present today's speakers
Dr Telmo Enriquez and Dr Jonathan Jacob
and joining them will be Andrew Olsen
from kyogen who will be moderating the Q
a session and providing additional
information for a complete biography of
our speakers please visit the presenter
tab from the menu at the left of your
screen thank you Dr Enriquez and Dr
Jacobs Mr Olsen all of you may now begin
your presentation
hello and welcome my name is Sandra
Olson I'm the associate director for
Global Marketing for kaijin digital
insights today we have what I think is a
very exciting topic to announce and
introduce to you but before we begin I
just want to let everybody know that all
participants are in listen only mode if
you have any questions please put them
in the Q a and we'll try to address as
many uh questions at the end of this
presentation as uh as possible
uh and just to be clear the products
that uh shown here today are intended
for molecular biology applications these
uh products are not intended for the
diagnosis uh prevention or treatment of
a disease
so uh before we get into our topic I
just wanted to give a brief introduction
about kaijin digital insights kaijin
digital insights is the software and
knowledge content arm of kyogen
QDI as we like to call it is the leading
provider of these types of software and
data to the industry with over 90 000
active users and over 35 000
Publications citing our products and
over three million patient tests
profiled with our software kaijin is the
Undisputed leader in this field
many of you know kyogen for their sample
to Insight motto but uh what does that
really mean we have all the products
that take you from sample collection to
preparation to detection to data
analysis and interpretation
and when it comes to data and software
kaijin digital insights uh has the depth
the breadth the timeliness context and
quality to help you make the best
decisions from your data
our bench to bedside portfolio covers
everything from basic research and
Discovery uh to Public Health to
translational research and clinical
development no other company has this
broad portfolio to help you with any of
your omics related questions
and today we are expanding this
portfolio to include cell line omics
data is with great pleasure that I
introduce our speakers today Dr Telmo
Henriques from kaijin and Dr Jonathan
Jacobs from atcc
Dr henriquez is a scientist with hygiene
digital insights with experience in
molecular biology Next Generation
sequencing techniques and computational
bioinformatics approaches Dr Jacobs
leads atcc's sequencing and
bioinformatics center and the
development of the apcc genome portal he
has over 20 years of experience in
molecular genetics bioinformatics and
microbial genomics gentlemen are you
with us
great Jonathan uh why don't you take us
into the next section here
okay be happy to thank you for the uh
very nice introduction so my name is uh
Jonathan Jacobs senior director of
bioinformatics at atcc and um what I'd
like to do today is uh describe to you
this new partnership that uh atccc or
the American type culture collection uh
has recently formed with uh kaijin
digital insights uh really focused on uh
establishing a high quality
authenticated reference uh data resource
uh uh representing
um RNA uh rnic data sets whole
transcriptome sequencing data sets from
our enormous collection of cell lines
and primary tissue
so if you're not familiar with atcc
where nearly 100 year old organization
founded in 1925 where the world's
largest buyer repository
um and uh we have a enormous range of
biological materials in our collection
uh ranging from human cell lines and
primary tissue to viruses bacteria fungi
algae uh
and uh everything that we do at atcc is
um heavily focused on maintaining the
highest level of quality and scientific
reproducibility in our materials so that
our
um our customers uh you know know what
they're getting uh and can have certain
High the highest level of expectations
of reproducibility in those materials
when they bring those materials into
their own research Pipelines
some of the common challenges that we're
trying to solve and address through this
partnership with kyogen is uh kind of
captured here on this slide it's often
that uh in my own engagement with
researchers especially in the biopharma
space
um when I talk to them about the
challenges that they're facing uh that
they
highlight the the challenges they face
around finding the right cell lines uh
to use further research they also
frequently will discover sometimes often
too late uh or rather late in their in
their pipeline that the cell lines
they're using are not actually the right
models uh to be uh for the particular
disease that they're studying
um and then the last issue here is
around scientific reproducibility which
is
um broadly being recognized as a a real
challenge in the scientific Community
um and what I mean about that is uh for
example when you're reading uh an
exciting paper and a top tier journal
and you want to reproduce some of the
results that were uh obtained uh by by
that outside lab that was presented in
that paper and you you bring materials
into your lab and uh and uh kind of
re-initiate your own uh projects
sometimes you can end up with different
results and a lot of times that's uh has
to do with the uh underlying uh issues
of the the provenance in the data uh the
authenticity and the traceability of the
cell lines back to their original Source
materials which then leads to sort of
domino effect uh that
um reduces the ability for researchers
to to reproduce the results they've seen
in other labs and so what we're trying
to do with our partnership here is
um establish the uh the highest level of
quality and authenticity in uh omics
data related to the large collection of
cell lines that we have in our own
collection
um so that researchers can can plan and
have some level of certainty uh in the
ability for them to reproduce uh and uh
results seen in other labs it's also uh
reproduced results they've seen in their
own lab from a discovery perspective is
also uh highly critical
so as we kind of move up this value
chain in uh the types of data that are
out there in the uh in the genomics and
uh Life Sciences industry uh many of us
are familiar with you know uncontrolled
public data that's deposited into public
resources than repositories like at the
NIH around SRA and Geo for example
um
the data that's deposited these public
resources uh is often put there uh
because of requirements around granting
agencies uh publication requirements
from different journals Etc
um but many of us uh have experienced
issues around missing or non-standard
metadata assigned or attributed to that
that those data sets uh the data
sometimes is of unknown quality uh again
the reproducibility is an issue and so
this ends up ultimately creating a
certain amount of risk if you end up
using this uncontrolled public data
directly in your own research program
without curating it yourself which is
intensive and time consuming
so the community uh broadly speaking has
answered this challenge uh by creating a
variety of different more focused uh
data resources some of them are gated
entry like dbgap uh for example
um others are highly curated data sets
that
um have subject matter experts that are
are looking at the uh the data that's
within them and trying to normalize and
harmonize the data across
the data sets Within These these focused
resources and this does reduce the risk
to some degree but it is often of
limited scope or focusing on a very
specific area of research and it may not
always be uh the right fit uh for your
own research program
um and then we kind of continue along
that uh that Journey we we've come to a
place where organizations like pyogen
have commercially curated uh databases
like what we find in the omic soft uh
platform
these are expertly curated data sets
where the metadata across experiments is
standardized uh we have a very high
level of reproducibility of these
results that we observe in these data
sets
um the data is findable it's accessible
it's interoperable with our own research
pipelines and this enables this
reproducibility this is sort of the fair
data principles of fair data model this
further reduces risks it produces higher
quality results in your own research
Pipeline and and there's a plenty of
evidence that that this level of
curation really adds value
to the to to the research pipelines of
many researchers
um but there's still one sort of Bridge
to be crossed which is uh the
authentication of the data itself
there's an often overlooked and uh but
very important aspect of uh data that's
in the public domain is that it's
frequently not required to actually uh
um for the data to have full Providence
back to physical materials that actually
sit in a repository that are available
for researchers to use
and what I mean by that is that you may
see certain data sets or scientific
studies that have
uh results that are interesting to you
but the specific cell lines or the
specific tissue that was used to produce
those results May not necessarily be
available
or if they are available or they're
named it may not be clear like where
those materials were actually sourced
from so what we're trying to do with our
partnership with kyogen uh is to
establish an authenticated uh omics
knowledge base where the data and the
physical materials are connected so that
you know that if you see a certain
transcription profile or a certain
pathway being activated in a certain
cell line or cell type that those cells
that were used to actually produce that
data are actually available and can be
resourced and brought into your own
research program to eliminate any
question of the provenance and the
traceability of the the physical
materials and also maximize the degree
of reproducibility in your own in your
own lab
so there are several key features to
this partnership and the creation of the
atcc cell line land uh this is a large
repository uh growing repository of
authenticated omics data sets that's
traceable back to physical materials
I've already mentioned
um the data production the curation of
the data and the analysis of that data
is all being uniformly standardized
through the entire pipeline from
the point in which the tube is taken out
of our biorepository and brought into
our uh our wet Laboratories all the way
through to sequencing environformatics
again this maximizes our scientific
reproducibility and it provides uh
researchers with an end-to-end data
Providence for genomics data
uh I would venture to say that this is
actually the first time this sort of uh
uh full traceability of accessible data
sets has been available to the
scientific community and I'm really
looking forward to uh this program as we
continue to grow the content within the
atcc cell line land moving forward
um in our collection we have a number of
different uh sources of the data out of
our biomanufacturing organization uh we
have a number of ongoing r d uh
comparative transcriptomics projects as
well as customer sponsor projects that
use authenticated cell lines from our
Repository
all of our materials used to
um for the content and the atcs and cell
line land all these cell lines are being
grown up and uh
um our Q seed using our defined uh cell
culture protocols atcc defined media we
have a standardized process for RNA
extraction and sequencing for rna-seq uh
and our bioinformatics and downstream
curation process has also been
standardized in partnership with
cyanogen
so what's in our collection we have uh
over 3000 authenticated million cell
lines that are in atcc's biorepository
including genetically engineering cell
lines primary cells stem cells ipsc
derived cells are very large collection
of h-tured immortalized cell lines and
as well as uh 2D and 3D organoid models
representing a a range of vertebrate
species cell types tissues and diseases
as you can see here we have uh over 1700
cell lines that are specifically just
for human uh as well as over 1400 cell
lines for mouse and a range of
additional cell lines from uh from other
mammalian uh vertebrates
further our human cell lines uh
our collection represents over 400
different disease types and
um it's actually in total it's actually
it turned out to be over uh 2100 cell
lines in total when you bring the
primary tissue in as well
um and for a wide range of these cell
lines we have additional metadata which
is often critical for research to make
um decisions about what materials are
appropriate for their for their research
pipeline including karyotyping
information age uh sex race uh passage
number uh the natural history of the
cell lines Etc
we have a fairly wide range of data sets
that we're also including in the the
cell line uh in the atcc selling land
that is around
um cell surface marker uh expression Etc
um so so to complement the rna-seq data
that we're producing uh de novo as part
of this partnership we're also bringing
with that
a diverse and curated uh collection of
metadata assigned to that those cell
lines to help enable end users in their
analyzes
this gives you kind of a broad uh
high-level idea of the range of tissues
represented in our collection
um
and here you can see some of the initial
uh QC metrics of our Upstream RNA
extraction and sequencing libraries as
well and I'm showing this slide here
really just to kind of uh give you an
idea of the the quality standards that
we're applying throughout this entire uh
partnership so we have a high cutoff for
acceptance for our our Wren scores for
the actual Integrity the RNA that we're
using as going into Library preps uh and
the typical
library
rna-seq library produced uh from from
each of our replicates has about 27
million reads so it's not a super high
deep sequencing but it's certainly well
and above what you typically see in
published literature this this provides
a very good statistical power
for detecting uh more rare transcripts
and I also want to note here that for
each cell line that we're including in
the land we're producing a minimum five
biological replicates so there there is
these are not just one-offs right we're
we're doing multiple biological
replicates and going through and
resequencing them multiple times
all this work is being done under uh ISO
uh compliance as well uh and uh using
this the a standardized uh RNA
extraction and and uh uh next to the
sequencing Library prep approach uh and
again we're using atcc validated
subculture protocols uh for the entire
program now this this further enables
comparability across data sets uh and uh
for for researchers that want to compare
their own data perhaps they have ATC
cell lines already that they're using in
their in their research pipeline they
want to compare their results to what
we've obtained it would give you a
really good uh Benchmark to have some
idea about how does your data compare uh
to data that we're producing in this in
this program uh or potentially are there
new cell lines or or uh cell types that
you might want to bring into your
research pipeline that have certain
biomarkers that you would be interested
in et cetera this these the
standardization of these methodologies
across uh samples is going to enable uh
that that kind of Discovery process
quite a bit
so this is a snapshot of the initial 250
data sets that we provided I think uh
we're now uh well over 500 uh in in the
atcc selling land now
um
this is a snapshot of the initial
disease models represented in the in the
first release uh again we're on the
second release perhaps Tomo uh might
have an update on that next
and this gives you an idea of where
we're going so we actually just
completed uh a survey of 63 uh cell
lines from human kidney uh and there's
about a dozen or so cell lines also from
Mouse kidney tissue as well that's going
to include in that as uh net data set
that data will be part of the next
release of the atcs and cell line land
we'll be presenting some of these
results in an upcoming conference as
well and then uh early next year we're
going to be digging into the Immunology
space and specifically looking at sort
of blood as an organ atcc has over 100
cell lines uh
um related to blood and uh we're kind of
prioritizing the TCL B cells in our
collection for analysis next
um and as you look out down the road in
2023 we're going to be digging into lung
spleen lymph nodes Etc
um but this this road map is uh open to
revision uh I really am interested
actually in getting feedback from end
users and researchers in the community
about what types of data they would like
to what types of cell lines they would
like to see this standardized data
produced for
um and so I really encourage uh the
community reach out and uh and you know
engage with us become a partner uh in
helping Drive the the priorities of
which materials uh we sort of prove the
front of the queue
um and that's I think a key a key point
of this uh this partnership is um
working with Kai engine is that we'll be
able to uh help Drive the prioritization
as well uh with customers
so again the atcc cell biology portfolio
has a over 5 000 cell lines uh in it uh
and one of the uh ways I like to think
about this partnership is is we're
creating an opportunity for researchers
to sort of be able to re virtually reach
into our uh our large collection
and have highly controlled and
standardized uh reference data produced
that they can then directly incorporate
into their own research and Discovery
pipelines
um without necessarily having to do all
the work uh of testing out and trying
out different cell lines uh one at a
time before they find the right
materials to to use for their research
and with that uh to tell them if you
want to go ahead and do a bit more of a
deep dive into the omicsoft platform and
what the atccc cell line land data looks
like that'd be great thank you
definitely thank you Jonathan and Andrew
for including me in this webinar today
so I'll just like to give you a better
insight and give you some of the
information that we already have
available in the atcc cell line lens so
with a sample uh translate to Golden
mines will provides high quality omic
data from cell lines and primary source
samples that we get ACC is using uh
because they're cultured under ISO
conditions standard renewed instruction
protocols and we can provide the
benchmarked SQL same protocols as well
so only samples that pass all these
rigorous quality control steps some of
them have been mentioned but by Jonathan
at sample processing and the sequencing
steps will be added to the lens so
getting the source material from atcc
means that the cells were properly
maintained have not been misidentified
are not contaminated and can be traced
to the specific Lots getting the data
from us and kyogen means that the data
goes through meticulous quality control
and is directly comparable with other
cell lines or primary tissues that are
available in the lens offered by kaijan
as well so now we offer data for several
human and now cell lines from immutaba
cells for example but also primary cells
or tissues and and a key feature is also
that each cell line has
um on average three to five replicas
and as Jonathan mentions
um up to customer feedback as well these
are Dynamic lens and the goal is to add
between 250 and 3M samples every quarter
we the users will be able to access the
this data through multiple ways either
through the Onyx Lab Studio GUI
interface we also have um kind of a trim
down
um more user-friendly version of the
land in the land Explorer but we also
can provide a flat file exports and the
data can also be accessed through they
are they are in Python apis that are
accessible through one except
and so one of the most common questions
in which cell lines
can be chosen to select or can be used
for for an experiments is by first
asking you know in which the line is my
Gene of Interest expressed origins of
interest and so here we're showing you
the Keras
expression in multiple cell lines and on
the x-axis we have the fpkm values so
the user can easy easily identify which
cell lines the Keras gene expression is
more prominent versus the cell lines
where the gene is either not expressed
or low expressed
another question
um that a user can be looking at is
looking for a Hallmark Gene and that can
easily identify
a specific cell type in this example we
have the expression of the cd3e Gene and
this is an all marking for T cells and
it is clearly seen that this Gene is
expressed in a number of
these cell lines versus all the other
cells uh cell lines that are displayed
here in this plot
and many times research is not based on
only one gene so we can also look at
Gene signatures and this is clearly
important when a user wants to leverage
workbook profiles to interpret some
patterns for example this can be
important when looking for a gene set
and that is expressed in one disease
versus the other in one disease versus
the normal control samples in response
versus no response treatment versus
control
Etc so many many much of the research
many times starts with the choosing the
specific cell lines and in this example
we looked at five different genes and we
can clearly see that two of these genes
are highly expressed
in a group of cell lines here
highlighted in the red box versus three
of the genes that are poorly expressed
in these Airlines so for example this
can be used for your research to to
compare
but um research not always about uh the
gene expression we can also look at
mutation data and so this is mutation
from the rna-seq experiments and
um
we can provide this type of information
as well so in this example we are
displaying two Georgette cell lines and
we look
at the mutation on by different genes
and here we can validate that all many
of the or all of the critical mutations
available in Publications that can all
be validated at 100 percent
what is genes and so this is for example
critical to know when you're developing
a specific drug that a drug that targets
specific variants
on top of that we can also look at
specific coding mutations that may be
present in different cell lines here we
looked at the tp53 Gene and we can
clearly select for cell lines that have
a deletion in green versus Cell lines
that have substitution here displayed in
protocol
or we can deep dive a bit more and we
can look at a specific mutation in a
Exon and here we look for the a regime
and this we can pinpoint a specific
mutation
um
on all these different cell lines
that we can use for your further
research
and with this I will pass to Andrew and
great thank you gentlemen both for that
uh really uh interesting uh presentation
there uh we will get into the Q a if you
have questions please feel free to put
them in the Q a box we'll address as
many as we can here but before we dive
into the Q a I'd like to just uh quickly
pose a poll to the audience you know
based on what you've seen here so far
today is this something that you can see
yourself using in your lab or in your
company if you could just respond either
yes or no to that poll that'd be great
and then uh for those people that that
uh respond yes then we'll have one of
our Representatives reach out to you uh
in the coming days and and weeks to
follow up with you
so
um let's get into the questions here
um the first one that I have here is
where can I find out more information
about this product I'll take that one uh
in the resources tab here in your window
there's a link to the product page for
the atcc cell line land web page and
then also a recent blog post where you
can learn a little bit more information
um about the uh about the product
okay next question uh this is
interesting what is the overlap between
these data and ccle and why would I want
to use this over ccle
well I can't take the one um Andrew so I
should mention that ATC land will cover
um ccle
um the goal here is to cover the
commonly used cell lines as well as the
remaining atcc selection that is in the
road graph which I would like to honor
to mentions
and this also includes some cell lines
that have never been sequenced before so
we want to provide omic data from salons
that were cultured under ISO conditions
where standard RNA DNA extraction
protocols have been used as well as the
sequencing protocols and for us it's
really important that getting the source
material from ATC means that the cells
will properly maintain have not been
misidentified and are not contaminated
and can be traced to a specific ones and
since the experiments in ccle and were
not done under either conditions the
samples
um in ccla and other repositories may
have contamination that could clearly
alter the results for example
um common is that atcc checks for
multiple pathogens like microplasma as
well
gotcha and if I'm if I'm not mistaken
ccle is uh obviously it's cancer-focused
right whereas I think the cell lines
that we have here in this land are are
Beyond just cancer and I think if I'm
not mistaken ccle is also very
human-centric is that correct
that is true yes um and um yeah so it's
in our roadmap to include
um Mouse samples which we already have
um and obviously based on customer
feedback
um we can include other species
great great okay uh next question uh is
it possible to request specific cell
lines to be profiled if so what's the
turnaround time for that and I think
Jonathan you had kind of covered this
previously but maybe you can give a
little more insight there yeah
absolutely
um it's important to understand that uh
what distinguishes this partnership on
the atcc selling Land from the existing
almost all plants that this data is
being produced
uh sort of in real time uh my lab we're
producing the data in response to the
needs of the research Community uh
according to our our uh our quality
metrics and standards and processes so a
customer that comes on board uh and gets
access to the the cell line land can
work with kyogen uh there is a model
where they can actually request specific
cell lines uh to be sequenced if they're
in our collection my team will go ahead
and grow them up and we probably will
have the data available within 30 to 60
days
um and uh but you know I wanted I want
the data to be ready as quickly as
possible for for the end users because
the the goal for me is to make sure this
data is in their hands and having an
impact on their work so
um yeah definitely
well and I think um uh Tomo maybe you
have some insight my understanding is
that uh for the land itself we're
updating the data on a quarterly basis
so you know maybe
um the atccc turnaround time is 30 to 60
days but then it still has to go through
our QC check and then inclusion into the
um into the data set probably on that
quarterly basis is that is that accurate
so that will come you know in the 60 to
90 days quarter kind of idea right so
yeah okay but still pretty rapid
turnaround I would think probably uh
yeah yeah that's great
um the next question that we have here
is uh do you offer HLA typing
information
I can I'll just touch on that briefly uh
I you know certainly the type of
sequencing that we're doing would enable
us uh to do HLA typing uh and that
that's a capability that is present uh
within the lands uh we're not currently
doing that routinely on uh all the data
sets that we process but to come up
correctly if I'm wrong but my
understanding is that it's certainly
something we could kind of uh flip the
switch on uh and make that those
analyzes available
definitely totally agree the data you
are producing allows us to include that
in the lens and currently as you
mentioned we're not doing that but it's
something
gotcha so maybe that just it'll be a
future update it sounds like that we can
do depending on customer demand all that
kind of stuff so so you know if you have
a need for that please let us know and
we can look at that so great let's move
on to the next question uh if we have a
cell line that we're working with not
necessarily from atccc can we request
that to be profiled and included
uh
it depends uh I guess I would say uh for
for many cell lines uh that we have in
atcc's collection uh they're also uh
identically named cell lines uh which
are often from the same lineage that are
available through other uh commercial
vendors and other cell culture
collections so
um uh if there's a particular cell line
that you're interested in
um
but maybe you don't know or have the
atccc number that's assigned to that
cell line it's still worth an inquiry
with us
um because it may be that we actually
have that selling in our collection uh
and it's it's in the collection under a
different identifier
um so
um if we have if ultimately it turns out
that the cell lines that you're
interested in are not something that we
have uh then unfortunately no uh through
this partnership this is exclusively for
materials that are in our collection
today
um uh but it's just important also to
recognize that there's oftentimes some
naming infusion about what what
something is called so it's always it
always helps to ask uh because then when
we can look and see oh we actually have
that cell line it's just called
something else uh in our collection got
it got it okay great
um so another question came up um so uh
will a whole exome and or whole genome
data being included in the in the land
uh it could be uh currently we're doing
RNA seek
um you know we had to start somewhere
and the majority of the data that's in
in the the lands to the other lands
today is uh transcriptome data so we
decided to go with that as a first pass
um I think for certain customers uh or
for if there's a kind of critical mass
of customers that are interested for
example in whole exome sequencing data
for a certain type of tissue or certain
collection of cells
um we certainly would I would welcome
the opportunity to discuss further uh
producing that data there's certainly no
reason why we can't include that data uh
in future releases of these lands uh the
omic soft platform my understanding is
supports it so
um yeah it's not it's not currently
something we're doing but it doesn't
necessarily mean it couldn't be on our
roadmap or or we could prioritize that
the questions keep pouring in here um is
this limited to Human and or Mouse
uh it's currently human and mouse that's
right uh there has been some discussion
about other other vertebrates
um as I've covered in my presentation
there's a
pretty wide range of uh cell lines in
our collection that are
um you know other other mammalian
species for example
um for example folks that might be in
the bioproduction space we have all of
the the top cell lines that are used for
uh biologics and antibody production
um so that would be something would be
interesting to look at
gotcha
um
let's see here is prioritize as
additional passages are generated will
the data profiles get updated
uh that's certainly something that we
can do
um now the way that atccc does are by
our manufacturing processes is that
um this data is coming out of the
materials that are in our inventory
um we typically do not
serially passage cell lines for Bio
production purposes we go back to our
Master cell Banks and replenish our
inventory stocks from our Master cell
Banks so the the passage numbers
um you know it's essentially like a
sister lineage but it's the same passage
number right okay so yeah
okay
um let's see what's the sequencing
platform that's being used Illumina
yes we're using aluminum okay we're
running everything on an XC 2000
platform good all right and then uh
we've got just a couple more questions
here it looks like uh that we'll be able
to address here will you be producing
um scr and AC so single cell rna-seq
data
uh we have a pilot project in-house to
do single cell rna-seq uh it's it's the
value of doing that would sell with
immortalized cell lines is maybe
questionable uh but
um
the
um but for primary tissue which is is
definitely on our roadmap uh once we get
to looking at the primary tissue primary
cells that we have in our collection
then we're going to be looking at the
feasibility of doing single cell
sequencing for anyone that has been
involved in single cell sequencing you
probably know that the
the cost to produce that data is
significantly higher than it is for rnac
um so for my own lab and in our budget
you know we're non-profit so we we're
trying to we're trying to do this uh as
effectively as possible
um but uh
you know it's it's something I want to
do so if there's interest in that and
your customer that says interesting I
think they should they should reach out
I'd love to have a discussion with them
yeah let me take one last question here
uh that is uh maybe this is more for
Telmo uh how many genes can be used to
query for a gene signature in the land
um we advise to use up to 100 for
um you know kind of
time but up to 500 can be
um
wow that's that's quite I mean I think
your example was only like I don't know
a few genes right so yeah that's quite
extensive that's great
okay well again uh I'd like to thank our
speakers today uh Jonathan Telmo for
joining us uh and thank all of you for
joining us today in in this presentation
I'm sorry if we didn't get to your
question uh but uh we will uh capture
those and if you said that you were
interested in uh having some uh more
information about this or you could see
using this one of our reps will be able
to follow up uh with you and uh maybe we
can address your questions at that time
so at this point that concludes today's
webinar and uh thank you for joining us
and uh have a great day
thank you thank you
and I too want to thank you Dr Enriquez
and Dr Jacobs for your time today and
for your important research and before
we go I want to thank our audience for
joining us today as well also I'd like
to thank our sponsor kaijin for
sponsoring today's webinar questions
submitted today and during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand for two
years until February 22nd 2025. lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time take care
everyone bye-bye